it's monday the 27th of july
directors do [ __ ] greetings from
podcastville
the church is brought to you by
draftkings listen
there's a lot up there in the air right
now but one thing you don't have to
worry about
is the bookie breaking your legs because
the action
is now at draftkings they got legal
sports betting
base right here in the u.s of a so you
can rest assured
your funds as secure as [ __ ] fort
knox
put your money in and take it out of
your convenience
nobody's gonna tell you what to do this
week
the bubble has burst boom basketball
is back bet 25 to get 25
how place a 25 bet on which team you
think will be crown
champion at the end of the season do it
before tip off
this thursday it's monday so you got
three days [ __ ]
and draftking will give you a 25
free bet to use on the first two games
of the season new users get a bonus up
to a thousand
just for showing up to get in on the
action download
draftking sportsbook now and use code
church plus for a limited time just for
the church family you ready
grab a pen all new users get a sign up
bonus
of a g note what's a g note a thousand
[ __ ]
didn't you hear me in the back listen
you can only get one grand
when you get the draftking sports book
all right
app you got to use the app and use code
church only
at draftkings sportsbook and here's the
part the lawyers make me read you ready
you got to be 21 old i don't give a [ __ ]
if you're 19 and a half
you got to be 21 all right new jersey
india
indiana and pennsylvania only i love
those states
deposit bonus requires a 25
time playthrough restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com and slash
sportsbook for details all right got a
gambling problem
there's help 1-800 gambler or if you're
in indiana
1-809 with it and tell them uncle joey
sent you cock-suckers but first
download the draftkings sportsbook app
and use code church kick this
[ __ ] mueller
it's monday morning i'm ready to stab a
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
excuse me you're blessed from america's
god
welcome to church welcome to church um
[Music]
this is what i'm talking about my bad
day broken
yeah i got a friend joey laporte he runs
a website
the hills of north bergen he's a
bicyclist photographer
that [ __ ] does four thousand
miles a month or something what
what follow him follow anybody
go on facebook to the hills of north
bergen
it's run by my friend joey lepore good
man
i've known him [ __ ] three-quarters of
my life
he's a magician but he's a photographer
and he's also a [ __ ] bicycle right
here
yeah i see it yeah and that [ __ ]
takes you on a different bike ride what
did he do
well he did something yesterday he's
drinking a cup of coffee and it says
congratulations to me
40 000 miles whoa it's [ __ ] amazing
and he goes up and down those hills he's
two years see i don't do the hills
i'm flat and i'm flat like my wings all
flat i don't know how to do the [ __ ]
i don't know how to do the [ __ ] gears
really joy we're there but you got to
learn them
some guy hit me up on patreon i said joe
you got to raise your seat you're
killing your knees that's the only way i
knew
so i raised he told me to raise my seat
and raise the steering wheel for my back
yeah and i feel a lot better oh cool
your seat should be
even with your hip with your hip yeah i
had a little lower
because i was falling like i was [ __ ]
you know i'm an old man like
what's happening christopher hey looking
beautiful like
chocolate or quarter continuously
[ __ ] thanks for having me i'm happy to
be here you look good
i'm trying but i spoke to you the other
day and uh
it was great talking to you it was an
interesting conversation about what
we're living through right now in l.a
you know i you know you watch the news
you see people across the country
unemployment i'd know the rent
moratoriums they just pushed west
hollywood's back
until september 30. oh they did yes what
about l.a county
they didn't say i don't know for sure
you know but this is the lee what's the
number of people it was like a hundred
thirty thousand just in l.a yeah it's
like millions in the country
so guys wherever you're listing from
right now i want you to understand
you're not going
through this alone this is going on
throughout the [ __ ] world
so if you were feeling bad on a monday
morning get those feelings and throw
them out the window [ __ ]
uncle joey's here [ __ ] there's nothing
you could do you know what i'm saying
because that's what
like when i spoke to you the other day
you know i love you yeah you do you call
me
i love all my people yeah but the the
same
i keep getting the same thing from
anybody i talk to
i tell you how powerful it is it even
comes over the internet
when i talk to people now on the
internet a lot people that i've been
following me for years
i feel like they'll tell me what they're
going through yeah
joey man thank you for the podcast the
other day
that was the worst day of my life i just
found out my company's moving
my wife's lost a job you know like
everybody's going everybody's getting
it's everybody
it's not just okay if it was just kovid
we get it
if it was just covered we get it but now
we got parades people are mad at each
other
there's so much checks are involved like
i told my wife killer
bugs killer bugs [ __ ] uh
galveston got killed right galveston got
leveled
that that part of texas done has [ __ ]
tons of covert and now they got [ __ ]
hit with uh
you know the world is in a weird spot
right now
and you have to accept it but the number
one thing you have to do and crystal i
say this for you because
that day i talked to you your spirits
were good but you got what i got
what keita's got her voice we're
concerned we're concerned people we're
concerned about people there's a lot of
people that are missing meals
a lot of people are struggling and my
heart goes out to them like i think
about him what's going on i look at the
businesses that are closing
i told lee i was on burbank the other
day just i went down and i
saw this barber shop and said grand
opening
and [ __ ] it was closed and i
went home and i typed in the name of the
barber shop and they had just opened
february first
oh my goodness you know and it was three
barber you know
three barbers that are well known from
beverly hills they got sick of
the overpricing and they've made a
beautiful website
and they wanted to move to burbank to
provide quality
you know they each bring years of
experience on set they cut brad pitt's
hair
that whole resume was written for
nothing yeah none of that matters to
february first it took longer to write
the resume and they were open
because and you think about it and it's
i think about it from me you and lee we
put together our life savings
you and us we we knew we worked together
at one time
and you went to shea [ __ ] salon and
you went to shay fifi
mm-hmm and i went to shea saloo and i'm
like this guy's ripping me off and he
like they ripped me off
he's collectively lee what do you got i
got 30. i got
22. i got 28. let's put it together
do it our way how we want to do it how
to treat people nice
you ever go to this barber shop over
here this is a african-american
barbershop you know that i've heard of
it yeah
they [ __ ] rub your neck and [ __ ] the
guy goes the extra mile when you're
going there the only thing you got to
sit there
like you're in the electric chair that's
all day you got to get that at 7
30. all day all day
so you know i'm in there [ __ ] one day
reading like a book and they're looking
at me i was reading like a weird book
and they're like what the
[ __ ] people read yeah like it was like
six brothers and me and then i was like
number two
yeah one time i went in and i sat for
like an hour and i was like i can't do
it no more
but a lot of people that know him sign
in leave mm-hmm
and then he'll tell you come back i got
the coolest haircut of my life in a
black barber shop when i first moved to
l.a i didn't know what to do
i didn't know it was a black barber shop
it didn't say it on yelp i'm not even
joking i was
on yelp and i got there and they were
playing tv and had music on at the same
time
and this is not a joke i finally sat
down the hair
dresser had to ask for help because she
didn't know how to cut white like white
people like i had the cowlick when i
used to have hair she had to ask for
help
really yeah oh my goodness like three
people get my hair how they treat you
though
great that's good that's all that
matters yeah yeah as long as i treated
you well
yeah but no what i was saying to you is
that i don't want people
like right now there's a lot of comics
at home there's a lot of plumbers at
home
there's a lot of people own businesses
that are feeling shitty about themselves
and i don't want you to feel shitty
about yourself i want you to remember
your accomplishments
i want you to think about your
accomplishments and what you've done
and that this has nothing to do with you
what's going on right now
nobody saw this coming nobody could
control it
you can't be angry at anybody you cannot
take it out of anybody
all you could do is process it keep
rapping with people
mm-hmm be in touch with your friends
meet as many of your friends
as you can throughout the day just for
one-on-one
because your body your mind your mental
needs yeah i didn't realize
how much i needed it till last monday
when i did ryan cichlid now i'm pro
bono like hey crystal what are you doing
if you're just gonna sit in your house
at night
and let those four walls crawl on you
what's that do from houston the band the
five the ghetto
the ghetto boys with the [ __ ] he just
died
yeah uh what's that look my mind's
playing tricks on me yeah right yeah
every time i'm in service walls for
the walls closing in on me yeah there's
one line and i'm not you know
i don't want the walls though just call
me yeah let's call and we can meet on
the corner
be outside and talk with face mask yeah
we could [ __ ] you know stand it's
important
one hour one hour when you go home i
tell you what you'll sleep better that
night
and you'll wake up feeling a lot better
the next morning
just that little rap that those little
raps you know
it's when you go to meet those people
they are stationary right like they
start standing close to you that's when
you're like come on man you're ruining
it
for peace of mind you give me
[ __ ] anxiety
and there's cops in l.a now that will
pull by you and look at you and
point at you like social distancing
okay they need to though they need to
and i want people to understand that
that blue sticker on the floor in the
grocery store is there for a [ __ ]
reason
stand by the sticker get your scoop back
scoop
back and get on the sticker nobody gets
on the sticker in the store
and they're placed there for a reason
it's six feet apart they want to get up
ladies i went to target today i was like
here we go
her buggy was all on my back if i can
hear you breathing you too close
you're too close go back i haven't been
to a store
i had to in months i i do instacart
which is more expensive but it's
it's more expensive and they never have
exactly i'm real particular on the brand
and the type and they might have what
you want if i'm looking for a particular
type of crackers
they don't have the brand i want you
just get some type of crackers so i'm
too particular
what a bananas they showed up with one
banana seed
they were doing [ __ ] like that and
that'll make you mad when you don't yeah
my wife gotta get in the car
yep and shoot somewhere you know and i'm
like why don't you just go
yeah knock it out it was always the
smaller grocery stores
that had everything like my wife tells
me i ain't gonna say where
i know whether there's lysol wipes light
salt and alcohol
that's what i'm looking for out you know
who else have alcohol seven eleven
yeah seven eleven got alcohol y'all
seven
did you pay the little dude off uh-huh
and you tell them save two hand wipes
for me
it'll save them when they come into the
door i got a little girl somewhere i
can't say
okay that's where i get the hand wipes
the lysol wipes
because every time they come in and i go
buy them you tell her to say
that okay i don't say that she puts my
nicotine gum up and two things
and you go get them yeah and i know what
day she's gonna be there she's to be
there tomorrow mm-hmm
so i'm going there it's a good day
though and i go early
you got to go earlier yeah if those
places open up at eight you got to be
that 801
and you'll see the the wipes the weekend
is the worst time to go
weekend is
everybody's out yeah all the german
where did i go oh
talk you didn't notice i got a flat oh i
didn't see it
thursday morning i went out and i had a
meeting at two
with these dudes from the show i [ __ ]
go to
do the the my errands
i go inside they eat lunch with my wife
i run to the meeting i get the girl i
had to turn around on magnolia
oh my god damn it so then i take the
[ __ ] car home
and i go to the meeting the meeting
started at one and we got out of there
about two and then i got in the car on
the way back and the phone was ringing
and you know on the way back magnolia
you just pull over and talk you can't
talk on the phone and burn back they
will pull you i
just got a ticket did you yeah for being
on the phone no i was looking up at
directions that's all they they don't
even want you really yeah they don't
play with you in burbank
even at the light if you take your phone
that they'll pull your [ __ ] over the
lights
that's good and they've been doing that
for years don't start with police
brutality i don't know
i was going to jiu jitsu one day and
that fool pulled me over
and he went he ran my [ __ ] he came back
and goes don't get on the phone like i
wasn't i was just going to see what time
it was
and it was the truth i was at the light
and he was out of light
and i just went and as soon as i passed
him
so this [ __ ] pulls me over takes
my [ __ ] comes right back and he goes
i give you a ticket but my son would
[ __ ] kill me
don't get on the phone in burbank we
have to give you a ticket have a nice
day mr diaz
nice nice oh my god tablet so what are
we talking about let me tell you what
you uncle joe what
look you're you're flat so i get the
[ __ ] flat
okay i go to the meeting i go let me
change the flat when i get home but i
get home about three mm-hmm
it's 90 [ __ ] four degrees yeah yeah
and my car is right in the heat
and i got a black caa shirt with black
sweatpants on because i left the house
at nine in the morning yeah okay on the
bike it was cold
you know so i took a shower that day
like i took a shot cause i had to do
something but then the guy called me he
goes he couldn't meet me so i go let me
do this bike ride
in case i go to pinocchio's and get
mozzarella and a bunch of [ __ ]
i can eat that [ __ ] tonight because
you've been on your bike that's what you
do yep so
work out to eat man i come home and i'm
like
terry you want to help me change this
flag because i don't know much about
what i'm doing mm-hmm
so together we could probably change it
you know i can figure it out
so i get this it's all new it's like
this small the [ __ ] jack
you know when i was a kid that jack
weighed a hundred yeah yeah this thing
is small and it's got like this thing
like i'm making [ __ ] dough
like i'm making pizza dough like what
the cats do you look at your cat
that yeah he's doing this i'm doing this
thing i'm spending i'm spending i'm
spending
the [ __ ] car goes up i had already
loosened the lug nuts i took the lug
nuts off
as i went to take the tire off the
[ __ ]
the thing tipped oh you have no idea
that can only happen to me
i looked at my wife i got aren't you
happy we're not driving back
what would happen if we were in oklahoma
and this happened
and we got to sit here with three cats
and my daughter in the car
wow so we ain't driving nowhere
this is why we can't drive when we
[ __ ] move because
it's going to be [ __ ] impossible yeah
so you always get flat when you have
something
yeah yeah no so i called subaru
because i went next door to my name and
he looked at me goes
are you stupid that's a new car yeah 1
800 subaru call them up they'll come
change it
dude was there in an hour i threw them
40. wow he
changed some armenian kid but now i got
to find the tire
he put the the bicycle tire on so i went
to goodyear i told lee goodyear closed
i'll lancashi
what good year closed by lancashire
guys good year has been there since 1997
when i lived in the valley
good year has been a staple there the
funny thing was
i just made a u-turn in there two weeks
ago
because i saw my boy was at jiu jitsu
school so i said let me turn around and
go say hello to my buddy
and when i was in there making youtube i
said is this [ __ ] empty
i go damn didn't i go what the [ __ ] was
in here anyway
so when i got the flat i went to my
usual place and the guy's like buddy i'm
all booked up today and tomorrow
i can't help you and i go what the [ __ ]
is going on he didn't say that to me
when i got home my wife goes yeah
five star went out of business so now
tomorrow morning i gotta get up at seven
take it up the subaru drop the tire off
and see what the [ __ ] they're gonna do
but i'm turning back to car next month
so i don't want to drop 300 on the
just going to put a mexican tire on it
over on burbank boulevard
there's one up above on lancashire it's
like america it's tires
but it's it was it's funny what you're
talking about how like you can't feel
bad
like sometimes like stuff like this
happens just to you and you're like
god stuff keeps piling up i got a flat
tire i
i got a ticket and and and my electric
bill's high
but now it feels like that's happening
to every like everybody is having like
this
we're gonna flat tie with what's going
on in the world right now
it doesn't matter you can't even get mad
about it
when you look at the big picture of
what's going on in the world right now
let's say you're not even looking at the
whole world just going what's going on
in your personal
comedic circle if you're a comic right
now
what about the comics that lost all the
work on the [ __ ] ships
yeah okay they ain't no bringing those
ships back for a long time
you understand me a lot of people are
out of work in all levels
uber drivers it's just bad you know even
homeless people
i don't know if they're gonna do the
unemployment i hope they do they're
gonna i hope they extend that
stimulus package they have to do
something they have to
i didn't get a stimulus oh [ __ ] i didn't
get a stimulus and i
just got my unemployment last month and
i'm still
appealing and fighting to try to get
back paid because i didn't get none of
that but i was so thankful to get
something so i was like yeah they gave
me some so you know as they used to say
beggars can't be choosy
but at the end of the day i deserve that
money because i wasn't able to work
but you know i'm just happy that i got
something now you got two
options okay you got an option to stay
here yeah and stick it out
mm-hmm uh we're hoping for a quick
vaccine
hopefully it happens in october do you
want to jump in on that i ain't gonna
jump on that vaccine i'm gonna let some
other people
test it out first so uh we might be
going through the second wave here right
now we don't know
there might be a third wave you know i
see what happens with china this week
that's very crucial what happens in
china this was happening in china
they threw them out of the embassy get
hit
the road jack houston don't you come
back no
you saw those [ __ ] burning
papers and [ __ ] boxing up [ __ ]
they had an assembly line getting them
boxes out of there just fasten them down
it's crazy oh man so what's my second
option you said i got two options weigh
it out
wait out here um this is the time when
you have to do an ego check
and say to yourself
is there a gig i could get something in
my income for 20 hours a week
get my podcast going yeah at the same
time maybe
be a hostess at a restaurant you know
you know restauranting is easy now you
know something
i mean this is a time to check ego you
got to pivot
this is a time to check you know i warm
a comic man
okay okay jokes ain't putting no bacon
on the stomach where you gonna do comedy
to yourself in the mirror
yeah so we have a problem yeah that's
that's uh houston we have a problem yeah
so you know uh some people
whatever it's where your ego is at
what can you take right now what are you
willing
to take right now you and i had a great
conversation the other day
about how many women uh flipped out
online and
i ain't mad at you you know you're
putting up free content you know i'm
sitting there bored at 10 30 also i see
the ass in my face
only fans only fans only fans is only
freaks
in that demon time i started only fans
yeah
i got my girl jamie i love her [ __ ] but
it's
[ __ ] weird how many women have just
gone
i ain't fine enough to do it for
starters that they wouldn't work
they're very beautiful and you know what
i i subscribed to two of them
before i did my pantry on okay one of
them is a comedian
uh-huh because i saw she had they go why
do you see she can't ever have she can't
never come back and do just regular
comments
her patreon her only fans
there's little other escapes that's what
i'm saying she can't come back and tell
jokes they're gonna be like
[ __ ] them jokes show me them tennis and
then the other girl i i
follow on i'm only i did it to learn i
also followed three comedians i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna i wanted to see what only
fans offered me the deal first
okay so when when i considered patreon
i i was looking around i knew the
features i wanted to see what type of
features
how much freedom i had so when i
uh chose it but i did i said let me do
this
let me my friend said he subscribed to
somebody it was 10 bucks a month
so i wanted to see what 10 bucks a month
gets me okay
and that one's podcast based i'm gonna
subscribe for another one for seven
and i subscribe for another one for 15.
just to see what they would give you
so far in two weeks i've given you more
content except for podcasts
and i answer your messages okay okay
i answer everybody's messages everybody
asks questions how to get
it's more like a dear abby okay you know
so
i went with them but i subscribed to
five different
three patreons i'll quit after one month
yeah the girl i wanted to see what the
girls are doing i want to see if the
girls were right
there and look i want to see if the
girls were writing like i would i want
to
i want my patreon to be a magazine yeah
video
audio a little bit of that [ __ ] uh maybe
a stream once a week smoking wreath for
a video with bubbles
i got so high last night after the fight
because i was torturing lee i was coming
over with an
edible but i ended up taking it myself
and then i couldn't drive over there and
[ __ ]
but i wanted to drive over there because
i wanted to run over the cones
i was just in the mood to run over the
cones by my house
when i'm bored there's this this this
neighbor that puts three cones in his
driveway somebody makes a u-turn in
front of a school oh my god and he just
eats away at me so whenever i get real
high
i just run that [ __ ] over and laugh by
myself
but he's been putting a brick under like
he's oh maybe how you got your flat
no no no no no so what i'm gonna do is
i'm just gonna steal them
i'm going to dress up like the red
whiting wolf
that's going to be hilarious across the
street i'm going to steal everything
his cones he's got like a little ramp
and then i'm going to throw like alcohol
on the floor and lighted on fire
like like [ __ ] uh what's his name the
crow
remember when the crow at the end with
that car on fire
he made a little string with fuel and
[ __ ] um what the [ __ ]
is going to sound like a hate crime i
don't give i hate people who put cones
up
i don't hate color i don't care i don't
care if you're gender
but if you put cone in your front and
your front thing
you're telling me you're a [ __ ] sack
of [ __ ] and everybody i've told this
story about says you know not even
meeting him yeah
that person sounds like a douchebag
because there's a school there and he
just doesn't want him to youtube
so i'll run over your [ __ ] cones
that's the cans of the world you build
me two times oh i love it it's the
funniest thing i've
he has been with ever seen times and
they used them we went off on the masons
one night
oh bastard dudes next to this i don't
know if there's stone masons
okay i'm not the real masons they're
like a half a [ __ ] club
over here it's a big [ __ ] building
it's a big building they're like
scientists like scientology just light
okay and right over there
one night they were out there with
torches there like three white dudes
with suits
okay i'm driving by with lee and a gay
friend
and i look up at these guys i'm like
sucker
they don't know what to do like who said
that oh gosh
you turning joe back and beat them again
they were all out there conjugating a
bunch of white people
i love your shirt yeah really i drove by
[ __ ] go inside you [ __ ]
they were holding their kids and [ __ ]
what is this world coming to they were
dying
listen if you're gonna do this [ __ ] one
thing this pandemic taught me is if you
can't laugh at yourself
or with yourself it's not gonna work out
for you you gotta learn to stub your toe
yeah call yourself a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
giggle i'm not it's not gonna pan out
for you
i've done a bunch of mistakes this time
like i've done a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
and i've just left you have to well
other times i go what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me do i need professional help
who cares what's that got to do with the
price eggs let's worry about kovic yeah
then you go get your [ __ ]
professional hope it's crazy it's real
it's really crazy and
you know what i've been finding well i
feel bad for the states that
don't have marijuana legalized during
this cove because if if we didn't have
[ __ ] to just get our mind off of but you
know it's been relaxing for me
getting outside on my bike and dancing
by myself
i get in the mirror and i just dance and
it for
even if it's just for two or three songs
that'll be about 12 to 15 minutes
but you feel better afterwards you don't
got to worry about nobody looking
blow you a little bit and get you some
good music and just dance
the one chick i follow just dances yeah
and then at the the last two minutes of
the song she takes the top off
and it's very weird to see
burlesque almost no she's just a crazy
white chick
with a lot of tattoos
really kind of autistic okay she won't
show the [ __ ]
which i respect okay you got to respect
that teddy
everybody got teddies it's like balls
yeah
i'll show you my balls because everybody
got them
everybody's balls are different there's
no two sets of balls that are alike so
even though everybody got titties nobody
has these two
so there's nobody has joy diaz balls and
nobody has crystal power titties just
the taste
yeah i know the taste of my balls is
gonna taste like
what's those [ __ ] what's those french
people eat snails
that's exactly what my balls taste like
i remember being like 21 put my balls in
the girls not from the highs opening
right up
like they put hot sauce out of me my
balls have been disgusting for a long
time
no don't let your balls be disgusting
they got to be i wash them yeah
but they sweat just naturally yeah any
time they did they sweat but
you know but if she's the type of
[ __ ] that i wash
yeah if i know i'm gonna i want to get
my tube cleaned
you don't show up some people do some
men that it's like they don't understand
that my mom used to tell me
you smell yourself first and if you know
you having company you sweep all of that
up
you clean your front porch and that's
why women and men need to landscape
because hair
holds in heat and and must and you ain't
getting
no favors if your front porch ain't
clean get that out of my face bruh get
it
i like a little head down that gives the
oniony smell like
especially if she likes hamburgers i
don't really like it see i don't even
eat
onions on my hamburger so i don't want
to narrow my sack
after a nice bike ride
25 my bike ride that [ __ ] is on
fire
that's a fire breathing dragon yes
indeed he gets off the bike
it sounds like the exorcist and [ __ ]
you gotta enjoy life man life to [ __ ] is
everything's crazy
covered bugs like you said we got all
these protests and
people being mad at each other for just
other [ __ ] like you gotta enjoy it you
gotta and life's too short people dying
your friends dying your family dying
strangers dying
hell it's a lot of people out here dying
the government don't give a [ __ ] about
us so they just
allowing us to human sacrifice it's a
new show dying on facetime
it's a great show they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] say goodbye put
the nurse up
what are you feeling
it's [ __ ] terrible yeah it's [ __ ]
terrible that's the new show
dying on facetime because everybody
saved it
yeah everybody saved their mother father
dying some show's gonna come up no one
saved that no one would call it yeah
[Music]
uh whatever that song facetime our last
words
on facetime yeah like 10 000 per episode
you'll give it to them
yeah you won't sell them the last 10
minutes of you and your phone
your father breathing through a thing
don't forget it's going disability when
you're 60
it works better so one of the nurses
aren't doing that because you know
nurses have with the hospitals when
people they're not allowing people to
come in
so the nurses you know yeah yeah the
nurses are helping out and letting peop
can you imagine that [ __ ]
you got a family member
it's been it's been tough on everybody
man it's been this is a weird time
that's why i kept doing the podcast
yeah i'm doing and i didn't want to zoom
i wanted people like i didn't take p
people have called me hey i'm flying
back in because you like come on the
show not really
if you're flying back in yeah where you
been yeah
i know you've been home i mean you know
i'm trying to get people who are
a local what's the matter i was gonna
say did you see what happened to zion
what happened he had to leave for his
family he left but he also spent a lot
of time at a strip club
oh he did but he did have a family
emergency
he needed to get his dick he can do that
in the bubble the nba is not gonna work
you don't think somebody else got in
trouble who else got in trouble
but his was his was uh it was another
little young kid that left out
that left out but zion's was approved
it's just that he got caught up
being somewhere else the other guy left
for him yeah the other guy
yeah something dumb yeah he said he had
bad wings
listen i'm gonna tell you something i
did time
because because
of the psychology of the
african-american man
they're not going to be put into jail
unless they shot somebody
they're not it's not going to work
brothers cannot be held down especially
at this point right now but this is what
you got to realize too
everybody ain't lebron like you got your
big big big players because you see
switching over to football what's with
russ book he ain't come i don't think
he's going to come back he's going to be
with his family
but everybody's not at the level of
lebron james making it in
with all the endorsements so them
brothers need them chicks
they need them checks so they some of
them gonna sit down some of them are
gonna sit down to the serious the
younger ones
oh yeah i knew i called zion a week
before he did it
that's 22 million
this bubble ain't gonna work playing i
see you go up to the coach right
can i holla at you yeah coach listen
let's wait till next year this bubble
[ __ ] ain't cracking i got four hoes on
the outside two of them are pregnant
yeah you know i think some of them and i
think too they they're allowing them
they should allow them
if they if they haven't allowed them
they sneaking them in there you can't
tell me they ain't got [ __ ] in the
boat
they got [ __ ] in the back they're
gonna do a lot of [ __ ] and then it's
gonna blow up and they're not gonna have
it
okay like again the players the low end
players are the ones that really need
this yeah they're gonna do everything
right they're gonna check the other guys
no [ __ ] really i got mortgages to pay
yeah i got mortgages to pay in that that
baseball's doing okay a couple people
tested positive
today for one team and they only hold
them for like two or three days
it's like two 24-hour tests in 24 and 48
hours
really so they test you in 24 hours and
they wait 24 and they test you again and
see how you're at and you're fine
wow yeah they shoot you with that's the
listen if you're a ba do you think
lebron james you're going to get colby
you're going to cover for an
hour how can lebron not
this is what i don't understand covet
can float around here
and kill up everybody but magic is still
living with aids
magic is as tough as nails
ain't kill yeah well it was really weird
it showed
who was affected there was a graph about
a week ago
okay do you know that people with age
it's a two percent chance of getting it
or something
really yeah the aids
because people with aids are in the
house
yeah they in the house because they know
what type of immune system they got
they jumping up and down on santa monica
they are not jumping down in santa
monica you think they're at the [ __ ]
mouthful whatever the gay bar what's the
name of it
i'm sure that works the full mouth
the deep throat the sperm mouth whatever
the [ __ ] it is
she is cheeks i know
i know that that those you know unless
you got
your young gay and reckless the old
geezers with
hiv they're in that yeah i have a friend
who's a piano player at a comedy club
and i wondered if he would come back
with the hiv
i don't think he could be around that
many people it's serious though but you
know what
do you now let me ask you this joy do
you think in your younger 19
20 21 year old self the younger
joy at 19 do you think if covert was
going on when you were 19 that you would
have been like [ __ ] it i'm strong i
won't this [ __ ] won't affect me i would
have been snorting
[Laughter]
the people that i hung out with their
kids their parents yeah
get your ass in the house yeah can't
come over here no more coker came
over here yeah we mean he can't come
over he can go to the yard all he wants
but he can't come in
that would happen we missing those
people in our neighborhoods though
we're missing the big mamas and the
grandmother you know what you want to
know why though cause now especially in
some of the african-american
grandmothers are now 40 and younger you
got a grandmother at 36 that's why they
talk about gigi back in our day grandma
was 65
70 years old and tario ass up and tell
you to get in the house
grandmothers are younger now so they
ain't they ain't paying attention to
these kids not one bit
so i don't get like i think until
someone
is affected by it until they lose
someone
they don't think that it's real because
you still got people out there talking
about it's a hoax
like how the hell is this a hoax and you
got people dying
as he sprays it
i just want y'all to know that's
disinfectants friday he's spraying
everything
i don't know if this is real or not i
read that a kid got shot in florida
and when they did the autopsy he was
called with 19.
so they put his death as covert 19.
probably
i don't realize i do think the numbers
are more money
yeah listen all i know is one thing and
it's the same thing i'll stick with
till the end of this podcast am i living
in fear now
not really do i think i'm better than
everybody else not really can i get this
yes very easily am i putting myself at
risk
no i watch my steps i see who i
associate with
yeah i see where i go is this necessary
right now
exactly it's just necessary you know
what if you walk into a store at six
o'clock
there's double the amount of germs if
you're gonna go to a supermarket at six
o'clock
that's just simple i'm going at six get
up
going eight rounds open today yeah they
don't want
you want the fresh stock you don't want
the [ __ ] people touched all day
you put it back down you know yeah you
got to go on a date you're not gonna go
out at night
i can't hang out with you yeah because
you're raising your
that's it yeah numbers-wise it's just
numbers-wise
if you go sit around with seven people
and goof around
outside it might work but it might not
work
i don't think it's gonna work because of
the fact that a friend of mine it was
her birthday and i hated to
uh shout out to sarah albritton i hated
to not go with her to her birthday
because they were in the park
and everyone was social distancing but
the thing is it's the same thing with
like having unprotected sex
everybody's saying the same thing so if
you're saying you've only been around
seven to ten people you're saying you've
only been around seven to ten people
i've only been around seven to ten
people
but when we come together like now
that's 30 people all together
and i just feel like is everyone's
saying the same thing like oh i'm not
around and if i can't i've
watched people's social media if i look
on your social media and you hanging out
too tough
no you can't come to my house i don't
want to be around you you can't be in my
car i don't want any of that
now the people you know i hang out with
kita or
sarah but the only reason that i didn't
go with her because she had other people
but
i got to watch how people i have to
protect me and that's the thing too a
lot of people
unfortunately it's easy to get caught up
into the mental that's why it was so
great what you said about
you know don't be hard on yourself and
this ain't got nothing to do with you
this ain't got nothing to do with you
did your [ __ ] job yeah you made it to
that
spot but a lot of this got in the way
yep there is nothing you could do
if you want to whine if you want to sit
back if you want to yell at governor
newsom
or the governor of florida or the
governor of texas
you could do all that stuff but ain't
going to get you nowhere this was an act
of god
or whatever they call it an act of
whatever
yeah on your insurance if you look on
your insurance you ain't gonna get no
insurance
because this is covered under some act
of nature or something you know so
i don't want people beating themselves
up thinking about what they're losing
yeah how much they're going to lose
think about your accomplishments
and how you're going to come back strong
that's what i want to hear
don't come to me crying now at this
point listen 2020
is done what your income is going to be
i don't know
i don't know what do you need to do what
do you need your income to be
yeah what do you need to survive to the
end of the year how can we make that
happen
look around what do i have to do drop
off you got a car yeah we just talked
about that yeah i don't want you to have
food in that car yeah
but if you could drop off films for cbs
like news yeah if they tape the news up
here they just
that's what you got to do this get rid
of the car payment i just talked to you
about it i was like man everything that
i need is in a one mile radius
and if i'm not going anywhere what's the
use of me having a big ass car payment
right now like
that and that's what you said you got to
get your soul in check and your ego in
check
because i don't care what level you are
on there are big executives that live up
there in the hills right now
that are struggling because i don't care
how much you have
if you've got everything going out and
nothing coming in
i don't care what kind of money you got
you gonna feel it so it's all of us and
and we can't be hard on ourselves and
but it's easy
when you're having like having a flat
tire and having all this stuff happen
it's easy to start feeling depressed and
be like man woe is me
and there's nothing wrong with saying
well it's me and falling down you just
can't stay there
it's okay to fall down that's
uncomfortable yeah i don't want you to
stay down you're in a bad position right
now right now you're plotting your
comeback
yeah you're plotting your comeback
you're like denzel and man on fire
he was in the hospital stitched up he
was he was sitting there stewie
planning how he was gonna kill each and
one of them yeah and right now
it's the same you know my wife and i had
a i love my wife we've gotten along
great during this thing
that's good we were talking about
college mm-hmm now lee's been to college
you've been to college
prayer um you graduated yeah
congratulations
thank you it's really weird do you
remember going to college and taking
your first loan
yeah pell grants black colleges yeah i
got a program
what happens when you get your first
loan what happens in the mail
when you get your first loan you don't
get applications for credit cards
you get credit cards yeah you get them
they send it on
yeah and they tell you call us up set it
up activate it
activate that [ __ ] and you
activate it and you go get yourself a
little 35
meal usually eating three dollar meals
yeah now you got it
but you're gonna go for a 35 meal and
you're gonna forget all about it and all
of a sudden you go to your mailbox and
you're like oh [ __ ] you open it up
you owe them thirty five dollars you
only made 250 for the week
24 hours a lot of money you know the
most important
thing in college they don't teach you is
interest rates and money
there has to be a course on guys
we know you're getting credit cards we
have to protect you now they don't care
about them yeah
they don't protect you from yourself
with children
you know the funny thing like i told my
wife i go
i know that when you're a kid when
you're 18
and they give you a scholarship and they
got your doormat just
they don't send that credit card to your
mother's house and they send it to you
because your mother throw it away
they sent it to you in the dorm room you
know everything is with you
you probably had a credit card before
your mother knew well i actually
the one thing i'll say my dad and he
doesn't remember it so
a good memory gone but when i was like
16 i had a job
and my dad co-signed for a credit card
but he said the first time you can't pay
the billing for him taking it away
and it was the best thing he's ever done
for me yeah that's what you have to do
with your kid
yeah it's about yeah so i i don't have
any credit card debt but it's
i have so many friends it's like getting
fat
how it just once it starts i've had so
many friends out here go to
uh debt consolidation this and that
and like because i didn't when i was out
here i was like how is everybody going
on vacation
how is everybody going out every night
how do they have a bmw and then
and then they come they're like hey i
just end up for debt consolidation i'm
like oh
makes sense i have twenty thousand
dollars in credit card debt ah
now i get it you know you have to go
into debt and lose everything
before you become a financial [ __ ]
genius yeah you got to lose it all
and i go crystal what is your car
payment and she told me
business i almost died yeah you know
what my car payment is
260 a month you know why you can get
that real quick you can sell a few
shirts i could always borrow two
i have 10 friends that'll lend me 260.
one time
maybe two but when she's paying
after the first time she comes back you
gotta put the bikini up
that's
it's like that chicken uh what's the
movie with ice cube
when the little cousin goes and starts
sucking dick
players
yeah it's tough man you got to like you
say you got to get your ego in check
they don't prepare you for this numbers
game so you're out there
you're mismatching numbers you're not
looking
you know like i said i know lee has
thrown ideas at me from time to time
and i've shut them down but lee doesn't
know the wisdom that i have there
that yeah we could go get a bigger
warehouse and put pictures and
denominations
but that's the first three g's of our
salary yeah
okay that's gonna be paying every month
every month and for you to
sustain that three g's i gotta justify
it by making 30.
i just can't take a chance to make 18.
yeah i got to make [ __ ] 30.
we pay 750 here we don't make 30. you
know what i'm saying yeah
but we could cover the 750 and i've
always kept it where
you're holding it's manageable yeah
listen i could always tell people that
we go pantry and i can get paid ads i
didn't want people to go through ads
i want to advertise for people that i
really like i like that product you know
i like draft kings people going to
gamble yeah they really gamble
always that's a great way to do it you
know i did my research
again from the church as they say
the longest professions yeah they're the
best they really are i really like them
as a product i reached out to them so
it's kind of weird how you have to be
honest with people keep
the pain you're i did for a dollar why
because i don't want to choke nobody
yeah it's a dollar what's a dollar gonna
do to you and i'll give you a couple
i'll keep you alive during the week i'll
throw you a life raft video that you
won't know what the [ __ ] hit you you
know what i'm saying
i'll call you a [ __ ] a ball
sniffer you know
uh it's just a time to
not beat yourself up yeah you got to
move to your uncle's basement
do it there's no shame everybody's doing
it yeah
everybody's doing it you got to get a
job something you don't want to do
a position that you're overqualified for
you know what what are your chances of
finding the job you've
qualified for right away why don't we
take this job
and see what comes down the [ __ ]
hatch keep looking but at least you got
an income coming
nobody thought they were gonna listen
right now if i was broke
and i saw an ad for a chinese cook i'd
walk in there
you ever cooked chinese before whatever
i can learn was it great garcia who was
it who got a mcdonald's job greg garcia
it wasn't regular
garcia when they had the writer's strike
i had a show on television
as an executive producer creator and he
got a job at mcdonald's to see how it
felt
um to see how it felt they saw they
noticed right away he had a head on his
shoulders
they asked him like a general manager's
position he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah
he donated the checks to the charity
but he just wanted to see what it felt
like okay
to be a working man again instead of
driving to a lot and
having people bringing you lattes that's
why i love greg garcia as much as i do
because he really is down on earth that
way you know yeah and this is what this
is going to help
this is going to humble a lot of people
but the good thing about this crystal
is that you go back to america's got
talent
hopefully they'll have a few weeks for
you to warm up oh
that's what i've been thinking about you
get back on that stage
you keep advancing mm-hmm and
that that's the thing if if they're
gonna call you i don't want you to do
this
because i'm telling you right now what
i'm hearing okay i don't want you
for him to keep calling him going we're
gonna do in september
and they call you september october now
you're 14
down in rent yeah yeah november now
you're 16 down in rent
and then december and they ain't going
to be a christmas tree
mm-hmm you're going to have a flight
already yeah you're going to have a
little cactus
triangle you could sit on top of it that
charlie brown tree
that's charlie brown tree why you
[ __ ] a baloney sandwich for christmas
because they're probably not gonna shoot
till january
oh so is
caa is not open until january if i was
you
you could be here i'd rather you go to
houston
mm-hmm if they call you and say you got
to be here monday call me i'll send you
the money
yeah but if they tell you three or four
weeks you
you take your time you drive back you
call keita you know you always got a
couch on cameras for a few days
and you go back yeah but for you to sit
here right now for fun like
yeah i totally i go late let's pretend
let's pretend i leave i go you want to
stay here
because this is what's giving me the
biggest problem right now is that lee's
wasting five days of his life with me
he's wasting 20 days a month with me
for eight shows he's gonna get
i don't want him to get killed or hit in
the head with a stick
you know last time i called him he's
like i [ __ ] can't believe it people
keep driving
race driving did you see what happened
in hollywood on sunday night
what happened same thing drag racing
yeah and they ended up somebody getting
shot
a 17 year old girl got shot hollywood
and la brea go look at the news so those
ass down awesome
told me that they were driving up and
down last night i'm like oh they've done
it for years it's i live on a straight
street
it is [ __ ] yeah you can hear it i can
hear it sometimes
why are you on the phone with him yeah
can't hear it and then he showed me the
citizen app
which is hysterical i saw someone
yesterday got arrested for assault with
a laptop
they ordered starbucks he hit someone
with a laptop he got arrested
you can't get the ladies and gentlemen
especially when you smoke reefer
you will sit there and your head will
break your [ __ ]
your little fat heart will blow up it's
the same thing with ring
like they have all those crimes and
everybody commit telling on each other
on the ring out
my neighbors be over there like studio
city valley military
oh my god someone just broke in a car
but i got a picture and i'm gonna go
after him i said you go after him if you
want to
karen get your head bust you got
insurance on this i got rings everywhere
yeah there's i got a good block because
the guy had two doors down from me
yeah everybody has them over there yeah
i got a cop that's like
knocked on my door you want to increase
your security [ __ ] yeah i paid it back
extra
yeah to have this button to [ __ ] deal
and it's a big
zoom too yeah yeah it's a big area they
get you now so they're going to get the
car
he put a camera for license plate levels
oh nice
yeah he got everything yeah so you got
to walk guys
people got enough of time on their hands
right now that's all they want to do
make citizens to rest and tell on people
and
you got to be very careful to let my
wife beep to somebody i almost choked
her
i almost joked why are you beating that
[ __ ] let him go it ain't that
serious yeah
i go where are we going what's the rush
well he was sitting there for four
seconds
who gives a [ __ ] maybe he was thinking
about his mother who just died two hours
ago
and you're beeping at a [ __ ] you
see a [ __ ] with a mask no mask
on and you got a mask on across the
street
that's what my girlfriend did the other
day do not tell [ __ ]
to put on she was like because what's
going to happen is you don't know where
that guy is
yep he went home his wife was [ __ ]
three puerto ricans to make the rent
because he got fired
he had to walk out on the walk out he
looked in the mailbox
the foreclosure and he's walking down
the street now and you
pull over like a [ __ ] guy you know
super christian that you are you know
excuse me yeah are you not thinking
about society yeah hold on
i'm going to kill the biggest [ __ ] in
the world boom but there you go
because you want to be captain save a
[ __ ] life yeah mind your business
they don't want to wear masks
it's their [ __ ] business you know if
they don't want to be cautious
i don't get mad at people not wearing a
mess i would never insult somebody for
not wearing a mess it's not even my
thing
i would ask you to yeah especially if
you're going to go into the bowels of
hell
i mean you know you're gonna go on the
train downtown for an hour you better
put a mask on yeah
you're gonna fly for five hours you
better have a mask on
and even then you better put tape around
that [ __ ] tim so i stay
so he stays and put a little lip like a
latch
just so you can put a straw in that
[ __ ]
because there ain't no eating you ain't
need not a plane no more
no because it's all closed up but my
girlfriend did that the other day we
went
hiking at griffith park and i kept
noticing she kept getting
to the edge and i was like why are you
getting to the head she goes oh for the
people that don't have masks on
and i was like oh i'm so busy trying to
make it up the [ __ ] mountain i can't
be worried about nobody else
but anoth a group of guys came through
and she was like i'm gonna say something
i said to hell you aren't i was like let
them people i was like you got your mask
on
what they're doing is not affecting you
let them go because you just
never know and i said and plus i can't
fight i don't know how to fight i'm
my core is real strong so i feel like if
i get somebody down i'm good
but as far as like throwing throwing
hands i ain't never had to do it so i
don't know
so i was like [ __ ] do not say nothing
to these people about this [ __ ] mask
cause it's gonna be me and you out here
getting my ass kicked
over some [ __ ] masks and then our
mat's gonna be off anyways they're just
pulling over and beating people up they
beat up three mexicans
see those fruit guys again you see these
hangings
and i don't care i am sorry ain't no
black person
i i stand by that and it some people
will call it ignorant
but first off i know people that have
hung themselves
and tooth the thing about people that
hang themselves nine times out of ten
they normally want someone to find them
okay then it's an act of you know
something really quickly
do you think that somebody's gonna get
in their car drive
all the way across town and have time to
think about that there's a documentary
on about a guy that for the golden gate
bridge
he did a documentary that talks about
people that jumped
that a large number of the people that
jumped all
if some people that made it they regret
it immediately
so you mean to tell me you think that
you're gonna drive all the way across
town
to go to a central location to hang
yourself your mental is going to talk
you out of that before you get there
you're going to talk yourself out of
that [ __ ] because i mean i think
you know i haven't been to that point
yet to the point where i want to kill
myself but i've had some low moments
but i just feel like people that kill
themselves that's a cry for help and
they really don't want to kill
themselves
they just they're crying out for help so
you got
30 minutes or 15 minutes to drive
somewhere to hang yourself
i don't believe that i don't believe
that i don't believe for one second and
if they had a video of people
think this is what scares me if people
know
now i i was going to make a funny video
and then i was like uh
you know how in the western they would
do a quick draw with their pistols
that's all we got now cell phones you
got to draw your cell phone out to
record oh i'ma record you
if a [ __ ] knowing that you gonna
record them still
can't control their anger knowing that
you recording them
what are they doing when they not being
recorded just think about that
if you know that if i pull out my phone
and you know that i'm recording you and
you still
so angry that you cannot control it and
stop
[ __ ] recording i'm st i'm mad imagine
that same
type of person if he catch a
[ __ ] walking down a street by
himself a dark street and ain't nobody
looking
in an area that ain't that's not too
much traffic i don't believe that black
people are hanging themselves like that
i don't i believe that black people you
know will commit suicide
everybody they don't have no no type of
but our history
there's just there's just i just don't
see that and it's dangerous out here
i've been like twice right huh happened
like twice it happened twice
yeah no it's been at least now about 10.
what what
easily cute man houston san diego
man it's at least i'll look it up and
i'll fight it's at least at least been
10 hangings and they've all
even the black girl right now i want to
say in mckinney outside of dallas texas
black girl
her white roommate male called her
hanging in the garage
well i'm gonna get up there come it's
it's more it's
it's a minimum of ten a minimum of black
people
all african-american but because of our
heritage
we're not going to go out like that
we're going to take some pills you know
you might blow your brains
i don't know but just to to drive across
or if you're going to hang yourself
you're gonna hang yourself in the house
it's gonna be something right there
you not that time that's too much time
for you to talk yourself out of it
to go crank your car up stop at a few
red lights
pay a toll then i'm gonna get out and
throw a rope up in a tree and hang
myself
i don't believe in that i just don't
believe it and i believe there's some
really evil people out there
and if they y'all saw that video where
they they they actually
there was some white people that had a
black man they was trying to hang him
and then they got it two white men end
up getting into it because the other
white man tried to stop it
but they were recording the man they
were trying to hang the man
you think if they doing that while
people recording them what they doing
when ain't nobody looking you saw that
other white man
they had him on a video he said they
were having some road rage and he rolled
his window down broad daylight
you better be glad this ain't back in
the day because if it was i'd pull your
ass out of that car and hang you from a
[ __ ] tree
[ __ ] so what are you supposed like
here's my thing
i try to avoid this stuff because it
just gets depressing
but like but then you're sticking your
head in the sand so like what are you
doing in the sand your ass is in the air
get it out of the sand
i know it's uncomfortable i even have to
be because you know
i'm not nowhere near joy's level i'm
still trying to climb and make a name
for myself
but do i worry about pissing off the
wrong person or do i cause right is
right and wrong is wrong we're not
telling nobody
to change their beliefs or to go one way
to other but right is right and wrong is
wrong
i don't care and for anybody regardless
if you white black mexican armenian
chinese whatever
if for you to despise and hate somebody
that has never done something to you
just strictly out the color of your skin
or your religion or your gender or what
type of dick you like
you got a problem you can't we can't
bury our heads in the sand
we just can't and i even get to the
point to whereas them videos get
depressing sometimes i'll post them
sometimes i won't but think about it ah
mod aubry
that video if we didn't have videos
those three white men
they would not be in jail right now if
we had not shared that [ __ ] video
if we had not shared the video of a
black man jogging in a neighborhood
and then some men saying hey i see him
let's go corral him on the back of
trucks they were on the back of pickup
trucks
joey they are on the back of pickup
trucks running behind somebody
if we hadn't had that video those people
would not be in jail today
is my thought because it was two months
and they still hadn't had a rest
so i i just think and i didn't honestly
i didn't know it was that bad because
like i told you if i'm performing
i don't perform in front of all black
crowds my crowds be white
and i've had somebody stand up in the
middle of my comedy show and
holler out white power that [ __ ] is
scary and
and all the people that sit here and say
man i wish you [ __ ] would i wish
[ __ ] would until you in that
position
you have no idea what you gonna do you
have no idea
because i sat there first one damn did i
hear what i thought i heard
then i was going like well damn let me
make the [ __ ] funny you know cause you
just never know until you're in that
position so
lee i know it's uncomfortable it's
uncomfortable for me it's uncomfortable
for everybody
but we got to talk about it because this
[ __ ] so imagine you got covered
you got unemployment then you got all
these races all these
these race wars and i don't black people
we won't win a race war
we won't have you ever looked at the the
population whites versus blacks
it's there's just no way
it's scary like i said i just got back
on my bike
just got back on my bicycle because i
was like lord today
because this is some evil evil people
out there
on in every race but now for some reason
it's heightened
it's heightened i've seen some african
american violence
on black violence yeah chicago
yeah but that means somebody knew that
they were going to be there at that
funeral
and you waited for them to come out at
their most vulnerable
weakest moment what made you do that
evil
nothing to live for evil and dope but
see
you know what unfortunately in the black
community we don't want see and that
goes back to what you said back when you
were younger
see your neighbor would have turned
little john john in the neighbor to the
house the third house on the on the
street
they'd have made them go tell them you
could whether it's your cousin your
nephew
or sister odell's uh son you go telling
them people what you doing that for
we out here worrying about how we gonna
eat we worrying about where our next
paycheck gonna come from we worrying
about if our
our big mom is healthy if somebody got
diabetes or
a high cholesterol now we gotta worry
about you shooting up
everything and we gotta that i hate the
term snitches get stitched
i'm telling i'm telling let me see you
do something
crystal powell is telling i'm telling
first 48 we ain't gonna have to wait to
48 it's gonna be first 14
i'm telling i don't believe in that this
whole thing has
made me change a lot in the sense of
that i was never raised racist my first
true friend was african-american i
didn't see
color i was such a young kid i didn't
see color
yeah when i got my daughter uh
at the church there was a man talking to
her one day there was two men talking to
him
and they were having a good time and the
one dude was white and the one that was
african-american with glasses on
and i said what did he say that was so
funny and she goes what the guy with the
glasses
and right there that told me that
children don't see color
yeah they don't you taught that it was
[ __ ]
uh whatever his name is we we babysat
him
he was deaf african-american that was
her first boyfriend
and part of the reason we're moving is
because that best girlfriend is moving
she's african-american we're going to be
living 20 minutes
that's the reason why we move so my
daughter
is not so that [ __ ] gets taught in the
house
it gets taught yeah so now so a lady
made a beautiful point that
uh took the gentleman that died
no which one very important the senator
this weekend
they did a walk over the bridge bloody
sunday when they
he got hit um louis louis yeah you know
and some lady goes listen we got to get
back to this
white people invented racism and they
got to put it to bed
i'm just here to enlighten them a little
bit and uh
those words hit me because it's true we
white people invented yeah invented all
that [ __ ]
and now it's time to put it to bed now
it's time to change it
but you had to change your see
the problem we have like when i watch
the black and this is straight from the
heart
i'm gonna drop some [ __ ] on you you're
not gonna wanna hear when i saw the
black lives gay parade
okay the big big one i saw a lot of
people that belong there
but i saw three quarters of the people
that belong there because
me telling you black lives matter or
i love black people whatever term you're
gonna use i don't like the word black
anymore i'm not using
it's african-american black is a hole in
space
i don't know where that [ __ ] word
came from so that's number one
no i'm not using that no more uh
the other thing today i was at the park
with my daughter and there was a
celebration there and i saw two
fine and sisters two fine ass sisters
beautiful classy
beautiful dresses on she walked past me
my wife was sitting next to me i go what
the [ __ ] are they going all dressed up
they would die
you think i'm gonna let that [ __ ] in
right away listen man
first thing african americans have to do
is stop saying that word
yeah i don't want to i i i only accept
it up to 2020 pre-rap
i'll listen to biggie and tupac but
anybody that raps from now on and use
that word
i'm not supporting them yeah especially
after what we've been to right now
there's no way i'm supporting your music
i don't want to hit it because it's just
about drugs and
hookers and clothes and money if you say
you're giving leave commissioners yeah
there you go we can't expect for
we can't expect for other people to stop
killing us and that's nothing black
people don't want to hear that and i'm
gonna get a lot of people talk [ __ ]
about me with this and they were like
you can't say black on black crime yes i
can
yes i can and i understand that there is
a reason it's some reasoning back there
but i know a lot of people
that grew up eating ketchup sandwiches
and sugar sandwiches
that didn't grow up to be murderers and
thieves so it doesn't matter
yeah so that's the whole thing they're
like when we start talking about black
on black crime they're like yeah but
look how far you know back we've gone i
was like but
we i mean a lot of us that's all we've
known is poverty
but my mama taught me i don't care if
you got two pennies in your pocket
you better stand up tall and like you
got a million dollars
so a lot of us have been poor and didn't
know where our next meal was but we knew
the difference between right and wrong
we had a grandmother that our mama might
not have been taking us to church every
sunday
but our grandmother was taking us to
church so you were you might have been
in them streets and you might have had a
poor
uh family but you know the difference
between right and wrong
i get it the thing that bothered me
about those
protests that hit hard with me in a way
is
yes you're out there marching for
something but how are you entwined
with the african-american community in
your life on a daily basis you're not
they're not yeah when you you have two
black friends
that you tell everybody about
and then you invite them to all your
functions yeah not three black friends
there's always two yeah or one or just
the token or just the tokens yeah as
long as you know that going in
you don't feel that bad that's the truth
we all have two black friends
that come to our parties but like studio
city let's get this area here yeah
that's narrow it's down to
every white family has one black friend
to invite to a party
to show them they're not racist yeah but
deep down inside that person needed a
place to stay i don't think they'd put
them in
not at all that's why the movie the
blind wouldn't get them the job right
the blind side is such a great movie
because sandra bullock
takes that big [ __ ] savage in there
that's what pisses me off about this you
know
when i see dave chappelle i love dave
chappelle
he ain't that [ __ ] funny not for the
amount of respect
he gets from the white community they
love him and sixty percent of that is
yeah we don't like black people but dave
ain't like the rest of the black people
they kill me with that exactly what they
say yeah they do you know he's not like
that
or with women that you oh you talk
different how is that what does that
mean
yeah how do i talk about it it's very
weird that i feel that way about a lot
of the things that we'll
pick one thing that we like african
american to make ourselves believe
that we're not racist you're not racist
when you're splitting meals with them
when they're coming to your house in
front of your [ __ ]
fancy white neighbors and you all wave
like
hey you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah this is
who's coming to my house tonight
coming to my house and they're going to
sleep here they're going to eat here and
you know
for me i was braised afro-cuban and i've
heard about the racism in cuba
yes it's terrible my [ __ ] uncle
he went to a store and he forgot his
[ __ ] mask
so he saw a paper bag and this thing and
he put two eyes on it
and he put the bag over his head and he
walked into whole foods
they wanted to [ __ ] kill him he sent
me the tapes today
of my uncle [ __ ] uh at whole foods
and people are throwing them out and
[ __ ]
oh my god he's [ __ ] 82 years old this
[ __ ]
and he's still sending tapes and playing
the conga drums and all this [ __ ]
you know what when it happened though
i'll tell you this because i'm from a
small small
town and it was predominantly white and
i had to call
you know my parents are in here so i had
to call my uncles and ask them i was
like man am i
was i being totally oblivious i was like
because i don't remember
growing up with these racial issues and
he was like yeah he goes your mom just
did a great job of hiding it from you
and y'all we didn't have the internet
back then he was like so
if your parents hid it from you you
didn't see it so
all this has done has exposed some
people for me
now i will say this the the white
friends that i do have
super cool called me but one of my white
friends called me and she was like hey
you know colin how are you doing i'm
sorry about all this
i said i know what's going on i said you
don't have to call me i said i'll call
your other white friends
that's who you call and talk to i know
what's going on
i know about that and then i had to talk
to another white friend of mine she was
she does
emily she does a lot of funny videos and
she stopped i was like what happened to
your videos
she goes well i felt like you know this
wasn't the time
to joke about stuff she says because
she's been like just
posting daily about everything that's
going on whether it's a racist video
whether it's
a homophobic video she's just posting
stuff and i said she goes and i feel bad
that i don't know
about all of this stuff with
african-americans i was like i'm black
and i don't know all of it i was like so
you can't be upset with yourself because
you don't know
i was like because how would you even
know that if you didn't grow up around
that
if you're a white kid that didn't have
any black friends you don't live in a
black neighborhood you don't go to a
black school why would you know what's
going on with black kids
you won't you will not know so
it is i do understand that there are
some people that have no idea
but when you have some friends that like
you said break
bread with black people talk to them
talk to those other white friends and
let them know hey man this is what's
really going
on because like you said lee it's a lot
of people that's just they don't want to
have the uncomfortable conversation
they don't want us you know they're you
know it's easier to stick your head in
the sand and just let it go by you
one thing i realized when i got locked
up
i was in the kitchen and i was around
i mean the two dudes i am now with
the two two out of three dudes out now
were african-american
you know one was from louisiana a little
bit out there
and the other guy was a big boot is
rough yeah the other guy was a big
time [ __ ] okay he used to bring coke to
denver
big time money big money brother good
looking like
he looked like michael b jackson
mustache and everything
seven [ __ ] seven of me on the payroll
um all black sisters brand new cars
mm-hmm everybody had a kid you gotta you
gotta have a kid with him and suck his
dick
jesus before you got a car it was crazy
and each of them
he would give him visitation like eight
to ten
then you gotta go because i got another
my other baby mama coming up eleven
she would leave it two he'd have another
one at four and they would all bring
them nutter butters
that was his thing and me and him would
eat nutter butters on saturdays and
sundays like a [ __ ]
but when you go to prison you talk to
these men
and you learn about something called
social economic prison
and it's a guy if lee gets caught with
four pounds of reefer and an
african-american gets caught with four
pounds of reefer
these parents are going to get a good
attorney probation
yeah this guy is going to get a
defendant
and they're going to mix them in with
another couple guys and they're going to
give them
three years yeah that's already been
found like they've
done studies yeah like that that's you
know we
if you don't have money for oj had money
money
yeah money money money money yeah and he
could
put it on credit and give you trophies
you know so you know you could pay for
justice you could pay
for not guilty verdict you could pay for
all these things yeah
with the right amount of people but
70 of brothers that are trying to commit
crimes
yeah 20 of those 70 percent are bad yeah
50 of them have had a problem they've
fallen into the system
they truly brought it i'm telling you
because i've been in there with them
with great african-american young men
that
once you get caught in the system it's
over it's over i mean i'm
like system was imposed to keep you in
there yeah
and the bad judges or the bad we will
even talk about the judges that's
65 and older that this is the thing if
you were born back
in that time and you got to realize they
just
changed the laws for racism they changed
their laws
but if that's the way you thought that's
your mentality
they just changed it on paper that's the
same thing with like brianna taylor yeah
it's no
knock arrest warrants now but the
mentality is still there they they
haven't been arrested
so if you it's a whole mindset but
speaking about this with where a white
man might get probation and the same at
what is a there's a article about a man
i think he
stole nine dollars he stole nine dollars
and he's
serving life to whereas you got
[ __ ] just raping women
and and not and doing what how much did
that kid do nine or ten days after he
raped
an unconscious woman or the kid from
stanford yes
oh yeah yeah yeah so it i believe i i
agree with you and also
that's when we started talking about the
black on black crime they're like when
you go back to all of that
and you're right if it's 70 percent of
black men that are in jail 50
of them probably had a bad attorney made
a mistake can you think about me and all
the mistakes that you and i have made if
somebody would give us a
five or ten year sentence from every
mistake we've made hell we wouldn't
should we have a hundred years but
sometimes you know black people don't
get that and that's when they
that's where the fine line comes in
between the you know the black on black
crime and
i just hate it whereas if they don't do
something about the stimulus
if they don't do something about this
unemployment if they don't do a
nationwide shutdown
where people can get back to work
when when people's backs against the
wall and they don't have nothing else
they gonna go out there and they're
gonna try to figure out a way to get it
and i saw a post on facebook when they
were talking about the differences like
if the billionaire like it's such a huge
gap
they said if the like the billionaire
people would give everybody just a
thousand
like they got so much money they can
give everybody on the planet
a certain amount of money and they'll
still be okay how is that gap okay
how is that how is that okay in in the
united states how is that still okay
in 2020 remember 1999 when everybody was
going to get water
and thinking that you know everything
was going to shut down we will have
lights and [ __ ]
that was 20 years ago that was 20 years
ago we was losing our mind going into
the year 2000
thinking that oh we woke up in the
morning we weren't gonna have no lights
everybody was going to buy a hell of
water and [ __ ] that was 20 years ago
and we still and look at this gap look
how it's grown and then they talk about
somebody being a trillionaire
they on track to be a trillionaire come
on man these people got to eat they got
we got it has to change but it is
changing
and i'm sorry if i'm going on a run here
i saw a comment from wes brown
the difference between now and back then
and i was so happy to see my
my white people out there and i get
upset sometimes when i see
more white people fighting for us then i
see black people
if you look in portland that black lives
matter that they was rocking last night
85 percent of that was white people
that was white people out there doing
that so like it's just got to be a
mindset but if we wouldn't have white
people protesting alongside us
now you think they were shooting rubble
bullets when that man went across that
street to go take that picture to church
if we wouldn't have white people
protesting with us right now
i feel my opinion we'd have been sprayed
down in the streets
quick quickly if we wouldn't have
jessica and sarah bell now i'm out there
protesting alongside the black people
they've been shot down the street i'm
sorry that's that's just my opinion
but now it's it's collective and these
millennials these tick tockers you don't
see people on tick-tock dancing no more
you see them little millennials on tick
tock dropping facts
dropping facts dropping facts dropping
facts and it has to be all of us
collectively
so i think by 2040 it'll be it'll be all
right
yeah it'll be we still we still got a
long way to go but we gotta
we gotta keep trying and we can't you
know we gotta have these uncomfortable
conversations and we gotta talk to
people
that you know we wouldn't normally talk
to and you gotta do something
you can't just be out there you know
even with my friend
well i posted yeah but haven't have you
signed a petition have you talked in
another thing i think we're at 100 days
for voting
yeah it was a hundred days that's the
other thing there's a
vote man what happens if trump wins
and what happens when trump loses what's
the state of comedy then
this is why i'm saying i'd rather you be
somewhere
safe because it's gonna blow up
america's got talent
calls you back you'll be ready you got
i'll leave with you i know he loves you
yeah got a couple people down there
this you know i love you but if i'm gone
i got nobody watching your back i love
you i love kate i love my girls but
number two i started a patreon and
i was supposed to shoot a video this
week me and damian couldn't get it
together
so the patreon is not just for me to
make money
it's for me to educate help people out
and educate like i want to donate to
like a men's
i found the shelter and burbank is open
i went to burbank to to see in the place
i could bring my clothes
and all that because this one's here but
this week
[ __ ] uh the mind of joey diaz wants
to give you a little envelope to get
groceries this week
it don't mean nothing about nothing you
know don't do that
i just want you to breathe for three
days go get a steak
go get some chicken wings whatever the
[ __ ] you like
go take the 25-mile bike right right
first you get all the chicken wings you
want we don't want to [ __ ] up that body
of yours
we love you on this show you always
welcome here i'll let you back man
once you go back on agt we're going to
get you back whether it's on a zoom
yeah we don't know how we're going to do
it yeah but we're going to do something
me and lee
lee's gonna take a microphone with him
on the camera and we're gonna [ __ ] do
zooms once a week we're gonna figure out
this church
i'll do something alongside but i want
you know i love you
i got your back you're my sister and uh
this week you get something for the
patreon oh i'm saying they're
gonna all right there ain't no nine
thousand hey listen let me tell you yeah
[Laughter]
and that's what there's a little taste
and this is what this is what we've
developed
here this is what i'm coming up with i
want to do this patreon a dollar a piece
big so we can put different people to
work
when i talk to a comic listen don't call
me up if you're a comic and say dog i
need my mortgage payment go [ __ ]
yourself
when you were rolling big money you
never called me and took me to lunch
but i know a lot of people how many
times do you hear me go down to the
comedy store and hang out
so do me a favor make me feel better if
you just took that
don't worry about what's in it nobody
knows it's just a little something
for you to go to ralph's and get your
envelope as though
people put it in this just left kitty
yeah
alonzo bowden posted the picture last
week because he had just saw it
but i saw it when it first when the when
the covet first started mm-hmm
there was a liquor store in the bronx
and they posted a sign that i didn't
see that yeah no teddy money yeah no
sock money
five [ __ ] at a time no
discounts
and i don't want to hear none of your
[ __ ] and none of your [ __ ]
questions
but that's it and that's that uh crystal
you made a great monday morning podcast
thanks for having me
man i love you i gotta say this really
quickly i'm over here snotting because
this is what it's about like if your
hands are like this
clothes fisted you can't help anyone but
you also
can't receive anything and i got a bunch
of people in my
phone and like you said they when the
times is good they're not i called you
twice
man listen no you've been calling me
yeah he was like yo
you're making me nervous and i told you
when you answered when i answered i was
like damn you checking on me
better than some folks that i'm i'm
kicking it with so i have to say this
like
for one when you mention you we all know
you get me into the comedy store
when i go if i don't go to when i go to
the comedy store if i'm when i'm with
joy i get treated like royalty i get a
seat i get a drink yeah come on
oh you enjoy you george but when i'm not
with you they treat me like [ __ ]
and you let me come on your podcast you
talk to me you
had me around your daughter and your
wife and i'm so grateful
and because of that you're teaching me
this and i get to do it to somebody else
[ __ ] this is what it's all about
it's all about logan bought me a
thousand stakes i gotta give those
things down
another episode of soprano when
christopher came in
he's like i'm sick and tired of paying
for dennis he goes what do you [ __ ]
complain about someday some kids are
gonna be paying for your dinners yeah
and that's exactly true so i'm grateful
so thank you man beautiful brother this
is what it's all about your family to me
you got my number you need something you
call i don't want you to miss a pork
chop
yeah or chicken i would with these
thighs i can miss a couple of them all
right
man that was what you got out of the car
i mean cuz i couldn't i'll tell you this
america's got talent did give me
something to
look forward to and to work towards
because i kept saying [ __ ] you can't
you know that
tv add 10 pounds so i was like whenever
we come back i cannot afford to be
chunky
crystal over here so i at least was like
okay but you got that you got that you
know work towards that but
it's been a conscious effort and you
know but and i'm i'm
because of people like you like i get
blessed and this is
man i've been blessed dog so i gotta
spread the blessing
and you're spreading it and i'm grateful
thank you for the man
tonight on the monday morning what
motivational monday let's move on
listen i know a lot of you are going
through a lot my heart goes out to you
you guys know that
i've been here with you from day one
banging these podcasts out
and we'll keep giving them to you all
right so hang in there
this through will pass stick to your
guns
tell the credit cards to suck your dick
pay your landlord to suck your dick
there's no [ __ ] debtors jail they
can't throw you in jail for all the
money
all you can do is not answer the phone
or answer them and tell them i ain't got
it don't pay the phone bill in the game
you'll get that call from 1-800 you're
like this could be hbo
this could be hbo and [ __ ] hello joey we
didn't get your final
check there [ __ ] you suck i thought it
was hbo and [ __ ]
i love you guys real quick the church is
brought to you by
giraffe kings listen if draftkings
sportsbook isn't available where you
live yet don't forget
about the draftkings fantasy app for
this weekend's golf tournament they're
offering
a share of one million dollars
nba major league baseball
mma golf draftkings has it all
plus player props live betting and more
they got legal sports betting based
right here in the us
of [ __ ] a so you can rest
assured your funds
as a as secure as lee's [ __ ] dick
nobody's getting in there
put your money in and take it out of
your convenience
nobody's going to tell you what to do
how to spend your money but i'll tell
you what we are doing this week
the bubble has burst basketball is back
bet 25 to get 25
how place a 25 bet on which
team you think will be crowned the
champion at the end of the season
do it before tip off on thursday you got
three days
tuesday wednesday and thursday i want
you know [ __ ]
and draftkings will give you 25 free bet
to use on the first two games of the
season it's that easy
new users you ready for this i'm going
to take care of you you're gonna get a
thousand dollar
bonus just for showing up again
major league baseball major league
basketball
mma golf draftkings has it all
plus player props live betting and more
to get in on the action
listen there ain't nothing else going on
if you're walking on ice you might as
well dance get out of the action
try to make a few bucks download the
drive king sports book now
and use code church church plus
for a limited time just for the church
family
all new users got a sign up bonus of a
thousand dollars a g
note larue you got one grand when you
get
the draftkings sportsbook app and use
code
church only at draftking sportsbook now
here's the part the [ __ ] lawyers want
me to tell you you ready
number one you gotta be 21 holds at
number two
new jersey indiana and pennsylvania
residents only
deposit bonuses require a 25-time
playthrough
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details let me ask you
something you got a gambling problem
there's help 1-800 gambler and if you're
in
indiana 1-809 with it
and tell them uncle joey sent you but
first let's get this party started
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use
code church we will see you crazy
[ __ ] wednesday morning
tip top magoo ready to go listen you
didn't do nothing wrong
hang in there keep your chin up you're a
bad [ __ ]
stay black patreon.com
joey diaz a dollar or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to give all right
have a great weekend stay black
[Music]
woohoo
[Music]